it was a day when Britain did whatever
it could to keep cool from pools to
lakes
people flocked to water Brockwell lie
dough in South London had to call in the
police after being overwhelmed beaches -
drew crowds from early morning at least
here there was a slight breeze it was
about escape in London we needed to go
out of the hustle and bustle of the town
and come into the coast with our kids it
does seem to be getting quite yeah quite
hot now then it's where it used to be
it's a lot more more intensity as well
yeah but for those who had to work the
record-breaking heat was a curse these
builders retreated indoors the drinks on
ice if you're on the beach just weather
it's fantastic but on a building site
it's not so great you know when you
start getting to temperatures above 30
degrees there's a lot of problems that
can be occurred with rendering with
painting with putting guys outside to be
big and scientists at Reading University
he'll be monitoring the weather for 111
years so we keep the thermometers in the
box to keep the Sun off them it's never
been this warm in July it's currently
reading thirty three and a half degrees
this time of year obviously the sun's
really strong and there's not much
evaporation to happen we've also got
this big factor of this southerly wind
brought in by the low pressure that will
come through on Friday in towards the
weekend but it's pulling up the air
that's really hot from from South of
France and Spain North Africa that is
really warm and much of Europe is baking
in the same heat look at the temperature
trends and you see the red flags of
climate change last month was the
warmest June on record and nine of the
planets 10 warmest years have all been
this century get used to the heat it
will be the new normal at the Met
Office's headquarters scientist watch
does July temperature records tumbled
they've warned that within just a few
decades Britain will be enduring extreme
heat waves every other year yes
had extreme weather in the past but with
climate change the potential for having
unprecedented extremes has raised and
therefore the importance of people being
aware and so for example the heatwave
advice that we give out the metals is
really important there because it allows
people to prepare and potentially to
adapt their plans someone tell the train
companies the wrong sort of heat damaged
overhead wires outside London sand
Pancras elsewhere there were delays as
trains ran at reduced speed on rails at
risk of buckling but at least one person
had the right idea extreme measures in a
warming world Thomas More Sky News